we got rid of over 600 bugs in the last
video so the attic cats of that app
should be pretty secure except I can't
remember if I remove the debug switch in
the code I checked in at 2:00 a.m. last
night stick around to see how web
security scanner helps protect you from
inevitable mistakes like this mistakes
happen even to the best of us no matter
how great developers are we are going to
accidentally introduce bugs to the
codebase
luckily Google's web security scanner
can do automatic testing to your
deployed code to find bugs and
unintentional vulnerabilities introduced
to the codebase it's really easy to use
let's see it in action from the simple
web UI and GCP we create a new scan we
pointed at a staging URL for our app not
the production URL because cloud
security scanner is going to be fuzz
testing or throwing a whole lot of wacky
data and our app and we don't want to
risk corrupting the live version of our
app in this example we put in a
kubernetes pod address there I'll leave
everything else at its default and then
set cloud web security scanner to run
daily and after about 15 minutes you
should be able to see what the output
looks like and we see here oh cloud web
security scanner found a few issues see
cloud web security scanner starts
crawling around all the URLs that can
find and starts looking for these known
vulnerabilities here you see it found
some cross-site scripting issues by
clicking on the known vulnerability we
can see the issue in our admin login
page just from the UI we're able to dig
in and get the exact way to replicate
that bug so that we can troubleshoot and
then fix it so we're going to show you
this bug live and then we're going to
fix it right now so that we can knock
yet another vulnerability off of add a
cat to that if we take that HTML from
web security scanner we can see right in
our UI that instead of showing the email
address of the person who tried to log
in our app is displaying weird stuff if
we go and look at the login page HTML
we're web security scanner got that HTML
from we can look and see that I
accidentally left in a safe flag which
disables cross-site scripting prevention
once we take that out and push that bill
to production web security scanner will
continue doing its daily scan and
letting us know about any other
vulnerabilities
10 the coolest part about this whole
process and the tool is that web
security scanner doesn't cost you
anything to use it's a free and easy low
friction fire-and-forget tool it's not
perfect it won't protect you from a
sophisticated attack or a new clever
zero-day but it will help you with a lot
of those common easy to prevent errors
that may have slipped past your code
review process once you set up that
daily scan it's going to keep going ok
the supply chain is secure we've set up
automatic web security scans this app
should be secure what's left me me Oh me
fishing that's right we've protected our
software it's time to protect our
developers don't miss the next video
we're gonna talk about preventing one of
the oldest and most common
vulnerabilities phishing
[Music]